angela merkel se retira después de 16
años como canciller y deja un legado de
gestión difícil de igualar especialmente
en la solución de crisis
puede dejar el cargo con la conciencia
tranquila después del 26 de septiembre
en su primer periodo se encontró con la
crisis económica de lehman brothers de
2008 en su 2ª cancillería no dudó en
apostar por el abandono progresivo de la
energía nuclear tras el terremoto de
fukushima fue en su tercer periodo
cuando mostró su liderazgo internacional
tuvo un papel predominante como
mediadora entre rusia y ucrania fue
clave en evitar la salida del euro de
grecia y arriesgó su capital político
abriendo sus fronteras a centenares de
miles de migrantes de siria irak y
musicalizar mendieta and fans y tenemos
que empezar a disculparnos por mostrar
una cara amistosa en tiempos de crisis
entonces este no es mi país
sainz en 2016 tuvo que lidiar con un
atentado terrorista islamista
y son asesinos llenos de odio pero no
les corresponde a ustedes decidir cómo
vivimos y cómo queremos vivir
intensidad política que no descendió en
su cuarto y último período en el que
destacan las últimas y quizás más graves
crisis la pandemia del coronavirus
desde la segunda guerra mundial no ha
habido un desafío para nuestro país que
dependa tanto de nuestra solidaridad
universal
y las mortales inundaciones del pasado
julio tiempo en el que merkel también ha
aprovechado para dejar mensajes
importantes en favor del feminismo y
contra el odio
no hay tolerancia para aquellos que
cuestionan la dignidad de los demás
contra su legado de gestión también
brillaron momentos cómicos y
desenfadados que la acercaban a una
siempre ansiada vida corriente ante este
legado su marcha deja una pregunta de
desamparo entre los alemanes quien va a
solucionar ahora la crisis de no tener a
la solución adora de crisis
[Música]